700 c'est le nombre d'emplois qui était
à pourvoir aujourd'hui pour les Jeux
Olympiques et Paralympiques 2024 de 10h
à 17h 40 entreprises toutes impliquées
dans les jeux étaient sur place pour
présenter et proposer des opportunités
ces offres elles concernent les domaine
de l'hôtellerie de la restauration du
tourisme du sport événementiel de la
sécurité de la propreté recyclage et des
transports logistiques énergie j'ai
d'ailleurs rencontré deux entreprises
qui étaient présentes ici aujourd'hui on
les écoute on recherche postes pour
l'ensemble des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques dans le domaine de la
restauration on rencontre des personnes
qui recherchent on leur explique
justement ce que l'on recherche et on
recueille leur CV de manière
électronique puisqu'on a une équipe de
recrutement dédié qui va les recontacter
ensuite pour recruter qu'est-ce que vous
recherchez exactement des agents de
sécurité masculins féminins tout type
d'agents qui pourrai être amené à
travailler avec nous sur les Jeux
Olympiques par exemple alors on a tous
les types de contrats extra CDD CDI
CDD CDI en passant par des emplois
saisonniers tout type de contrat était à
décrocher le tout en ayant ou pas des
qualifications le but était clair faire
des jeux olympiques et paralympiques une
opportunité pour toutes et tous au total
plus de 2000 personnes étaient attendu
aujourd'hui j'en ai rencontré plusieurs
on les écoute tout de suite j'ai pu
laisser mon CV parce que moi je suis en
reconversion professionnelle pour les
travailleurs handicapés j'ai pas mal de
petites opportunités mais il faut que
internet directement en ce moment je
recherche un emploi je me cherche je
cherche un attendant d'autres pistes et
je suis ouvert au plus de choses
possibles dans mes compétences si vous
avez raté cette journée rassurez-vous
vous pouvez retrouver plusieurs offres
d'emploi pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques sur poulemploi.fr ou
emploi
2024.fr